and about 80 of Amazon deforestations
because of the meat industry
wow yeah it's it's just this is wow I
think I read somewhere that Amazon
forests are being deforested at the pace
of one Belgium a year
So This Time Country Belgium oh my God
and this is done just to be able to
produce more and more meat
uh unbelievable that's unbelievable and
and and we're talking about roughly 20
of global gas emissions which is the
main cause for a global warming that is
caused because of this industry
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
welcome to 20 minute leaders today I'm
with Dr ishaimi Shore
mte's founder prior to mte mishai was
founder and CEO of Anna mishpat illegal
Tech startup his 20-year career spans
law business Academia and politics
including serving as Chief of Staff to
the president of Israel hishai holds a
PhD in law from the University of Oxford
and was a professor at Oxford if you're
interested in the future of meet and
meet the end this is ishaimisho
foreign
[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
so much for joining me today how are you
I'm good thanks for having me I'm
sitting here at the plant and both of us
already for the interview
I I love it and I love the entrance with
the inside joke from right before we we
started the podcast Isha your your
journey is is phenomenal uh from
um you know from from the political
scene and making a huge difference
um with the government here to Academia
to Legal Tech and startups to now food
Tech running a company meet the end with
with a very very clear mission statement
I'm very curious to unpack and unravel a
little bit about you know what you guys
are doing and and a little bit about how
you're bringing that Vision to life and
and uh and so I perhaps you can start
tell me a little bit about meet the end
as what you're doing and then I'd love
to backtrack and sort of go through your
journey quickly and understand how all
these pieces fit together to form what
you're doing today
sure so with the end is a footer company
or about two years old we produce and
develop a protein ingredients for the
meat alternative industry with the idea
that if we can produce better more
attractive more tasty and cheaper
ingredients that will have helped the
entire industry speed up this transition
from meat to the Alternatives of meat
um this company has I mean what we sell
are ingredients and formulas so to
clients which are food companies so it's
a B2B company
the philosophy behind that is that if we
can get in touch with as many food
companies around the world that will
help us make wide impact
ah amazing that's the that's the main
idea here yeah
well there's a lot to unpack from this
main idea and um and before we do that
take me back to to some of your previous
experiences and I'm kid I'm really
curious and to hear them in the context
of what what what you extracted from
those experiences what do you learned as
a leader yourself whether it be as you
know Chief of Staff to the president of
Israel doing a PhD in law from
University of Oxford lecturing there to
running your company enemy spot so let's
go through some of these experiences as
a Cheyenne and share with me a little
bit about what what qualities or what
lessons you've learned that made a
profound impact on the way that you are
a leader today
okay well hey everyone I I studied law
and economics for undergrad in Jerusalem
and what always attracted me was the
macro questions in in studies of
Economics as as well as in law so always
looking at I mean I always found big
picture to be really intriguing uh I did
my uh my masters and my PhD in
combination of Mark for economic
theories and constitutional law so again
from the legal and the economic
perspective
um and I was always very drawn into
places where you can use
um
um deeper thinking and planning in one
word strategy
to make our lives better
the public landing can affect our
through politics yes so our social
policy Economic Policy education policy
and so on and
so that was the kind of like the first
step I did is uh you know right off to
graduation uh I weren't for uh about a
year and the Israeli Supreme Court I was
very lucky to be the last clerk
who was well as Chief Justice of the
Supreme Court like the mythological
judge
um and right after that like there was a
weekend of rest and right after that I
went to work in the Commission in the
park and the reason why I'm using this
it's for me like this star
uh a kind of uh a really crazy
professional story because the
difference between working in the court
and working in the parliament is all the
difference that you can think of when
you when you when you think about public
policy
and in the classes I did uh
several positions of strategy and
management
um
and what was always uh really
interesting for me is to see how you can
again as I said if you how you can
generate plans for policy and then see
them you're not going through
identifying a problem and thinking about
solution
um
and then and then I hit reality then
there was like this big brick wall
called reality which in important is
it's a very it's a very very hard world
to hit
I I heard the reality coming in right
now it was uh
yeah there's uh someone really smart
that I love the uh the guy who wrote uh
he just uh
Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy Galaxy
yeah so in the second book the one but
the restaurant at the end of the
universe says that uh it says right she
said the major problem one of the major
problems and for the several and with
governing people is that you get to do
it
I mean who you get to do it and it's
it's a well-known fact that people who
once who rule other people
are those least suited to do it so
anyone capable of getting himself or
herself elected President should by no
account be allowed to do the job uh
but there's something later and see
um problematic when you think about it
because what you need to have in you
to be elected for a high position in
politics
is a set of skills that are very
different
from the ones you need to be a good
governor
some people are so lucky to have both of
these sets
and these are the big leaders that we
have but most people if they are good in
being elected
they aren't necessarily good in
governing
and I think that this is a problem that
we have not only an Israeli politics but
all over the world uh it doesn't mean we
don't need politics politics is our only
way of doing stuff
um
you know is a country is a society we
have to have it but I don't think it was
I didn't find myself there in the last
few years when I was working as in the
president's Chambers in Israel and later
with the head of position I was dealing
quite a lot with climate change
[Music]
because it is truly a a catastrophe that
we are all you know driving into and
there are very not Simple Solution but
very clear solutions for what we need to
do and still our political systems and
again all over the world just failed to
do the obvious failed to do what is hard
but it is undoubtedly necessary
and that's like the beginning of my
realization that
politics may not be
the right place to advance change in
this in this field
wow okay so so share with me sort of
this brick wall that you've hit and sort
of the realization of what's happening
and because it sounds like it really LED
you to do a shift in mindset over where
you want to be spending your time and
what your contribution is
through your work so what was it really
about you know the situation and the
climate change crisis
um that coupled with your own
personality that led you to start me to
the end what was this constellation
together here
I want to take like two steps back and
say something general about life about
the food industry because this it was
very quickly I realized that the place
to make change as an entrepreneur is
through food why is that everybody knows
this is a very well used fact that the
food industry is one of the leading
causes in many aspects the single most
destructive industry to our planet
from Industrial Revolution
humankind has managed to improve
immensely our production capabilities
and we now can produce so much stuff
that generates more uh
um
[Music]
more and more demands and this is true
in everything in clothing in in
communication and it could
problem is what is the cost for that we
produce today so much more food than we
need
it's certain countries and I'm not even
getting into the question of how we
uh you know what's the distribution
between different countries and between
continents which is another problem here
and this is leading us into a an
absolutely devastating rare consequences
um the food system uh and and
specifically animal based
food industry
has managed to create an unbelievable
um
um effective uh Mass scale production
capabilities and this is serving uh
demand that is much higher than what we
really ate and the outcome is
deforestation
about 80 of Amazon deforestations
because of the meat industry
wow yeah it's it's just this is wow I
think I read somewhere that Amazon
forests are being deforested at the pace
of one Belgium a year
So This Time Country Belgium oh my God
and this is done just to be able to
produce more and more meat
uh unbelievable that's unbelievable and
and and we're talking about roughly 20
of global gas emissions which is the
main cause for a global warming that is
caused because of this industry
um
the solution is under our nose it's
about it and it's something that each
and every one of us can do and that's
just really solid consumption I'm not
vegan I'm not vegetarian I eat meat but
I eat meat once a week
and I think I don't know what the
average is in in Israel but I guess it's
around five six times a week to eat meat
if you only reduce let's say twice three
times
the amount of meat that you consume per
week that is a huge help if it comes
from Millions tens of millions and then
billions of people
and that's where I'm thinking about the
food industry
that's what I want so now I'm going to
ask you um
so you're a strategist so I get to ask
you a strategic question that I've been
pondering myself and I'm curious to hear
your your thoughts on this
you know I'm thinking what does it take
to move the needle for the meat industry
for the vegan industry just like
yourself I'm I'm in I'm not vegan and
I'm not a vegetarian but I I find myself
over time eating less and less meat and
I've always said that once the
alternative products
um give us similar experience to the
ones we've gotten accustomed to as a
society only then we'll be able to drive
consumer consumer Behavior change so I'm
sort of already giving you my own
perspective but but I'm curious to hear
what does it really really take to move
the needles because it doesn't feel like
that more explainability and more
convincing is going to do much when it
comes down to Consumer decision making
so so give me a little bit about your
take not just as the as the founder of
me to the end but as a strategist who
understands the complexity of the of
these Moving Systems absolutely it's all
right what you just said it's in every
study that I've managed to get
that is trying to identify what makes
people buy food or choose a certain food
product over the other there are two
main reasons why people families make
their choices in the supermarket number
one is taste and number two is cost
it's not about veganism or about the cut
the world or environment right it's much
more about cost and how and if it's
tasty or not and this is why what I
think is that the way we can help
accelerate the switch from meat to meat
Alternatives is by
um
giving out more attractive more tasty
Solutions
only if the industry will know how to
create very appealing and tasty meat
Alternatives and to do the right cost
will we be able to make
difference in the big numbers
that's it and so for
and so so if we're now looking at the
gap between that what you just said is a
strategy to
to where we're at today what what needs
to happen for us to make this sleep and
and where does meet the end
where does it fall into this into this
puzzle that's happening
I think the solution is in one word
which is industry
right from the start our company was
thinking industry talking industry
trying to come up with solutions that
are industry relevant
in the input business in the food Tech
business
um especially if you're doing innovation
you begin with lab scale think of a
difference between a kitchen where you
make a cake and your kitchen in a
factory when you produce tons of that
thing every day
with solutions that are tasty and cheap
and that you can produce them Mass scale
because animal protein is produced Mass
scale and you have to come up with
Alternatives that are also Mass scale so
right from the start uh
first thing I did was to speak with as
many industry veterans that I could from
Israel and outside and the founders of
of cell media and the bunch of
senior technologists coming from
Unilever Nestle and Strauss Strauss
popes as you know one of the largest
food companies in Israel
um one of our Founders was Chief
Technologies for Nestle Israel another
one was Chief mechanical engineer for
Unilever Israel and so on and so on we
have a group of really well experienced
um our veterans of this industry and
what is the advantage that we have here
is not only because of their specific
expertise in plant-based development but
also their understanding in strategy of
food industry in the backstage of food
industry in how you communicate with
food companies so this is a startup that
is although we are just a baby startup
two years old we are always aiming to
talk life the big player and to offer
them solutions that are relevant in
terms of ingredient price of the
relevance of our ingredients to their
production techniques and so on if we
manage to find solutions that are
industry oriented in scope in production
techniques in the kind of ingredients
we're using as if we fit into the
industry we will allow the industry to
make this transition more quickly and to
offer better products for for the
consumers
amazing and so so if we were to talking
three to five years down the line and I
would ask you now you say what's your
vision for me to the end if what what
what is the role of me at the end you
know very tangibly in within the the the
food tech industry how would you
describe it three to five years down the
line it's a global leader of protein
ingredients
and I see three steps of getting there
number one is establishing that thing so
we have a an amazing technology for
helpful modulate texture in neat
Alternatives and through plant and
cultured protein
that's phase number one getting this
thing to work selling it out in the
market becoming a company on its own
right we're already there next month we
are in uh launching our products in one
of the leading food chain uh companies
in the world
wow step one step two is making it
bigger making it so big that you can
have influence and step three once we
become big enough is to make this impact
I would really want to see a food
industry that is more responsible
for the industry that creates
healthier food food that is more healthy
to our environment and a food that is
more responsible in the sense that it's
transparent and showing the consumers
exactly what they're buying uh we need
to get our boot system to reflect our
plans for the future as a human race
and for that we need to take better care
of our own health better care for our
planet and better care of the
ingredients that we're using and
the way to get there I think is to focus
on the ingredient side of the food of
the food system so B2B backstage I you
know something I learned is that all
those food companies that we know the
big guys
and
let's play and Beyond me it's in
Unilever and hello these companies
are creating a marketing and
distribution and demand they are experts
of understanding what the consumer wants
but in the end
the companies that make food
are the Commodities companies so the
companies in the back those who sell
sugar and right and flour and so on and
so on and I think that's a way to be to
make this industry more responsible is
to be involved in the backstage in the
b2p industry
I I love the internet yeah it sounds
like you've given this a lot of thought
and you're being very intentional and
strategic with what it means to to
become a and Game Changers you're not
just uh for selling purposes and to
succeed as a starter but also but really
to to shift
um what what this industry really needs
from the backstage from the backbone as
you mentioned it and uh I wish you best
of luck with me to the end with uh what
it sounds like is a real mission for you
to to make an impact
um following some uh you know a really
interesting Journey that that led you
there and and there's always there's so
many also pieces in your journey that we
didn't even get to so just it's even
more it's even more interesting so shy
best of luck with me in the end thank
you very very much stay safe and stay
healthy and I look forward to following
the journey